today we we live in an always connected
world
digitalization and digital tools have
brought
many new opportunities both in our
personal
and also in our working lives but it has
also its pitfalls such as the constant
pressure on workers
to always be reachable to always be
available at all times creating digital
obesity that can intensify work and
extend working hours
with a detrimental effect on workers
fundamental rights
unfair working conditions unfair
remuneration
on working time and work-life balance on
health and safety at work on
the equality between men and women
during lockdown
one in three workers started working
from home
this has saved countless lives but many
workers
suffer and are suffering from harmful
side effects
such as isolation such as fatigue such
as depression burnouts muscular
or eye illnesses people who regularly
work from home
are twice as likely to work more than
the maximum 48 hours
the boundaries between work and private
life have become blurred
the human cost is high from unpair
unpaid
overtime to exhaustion to burnouts
it is fundamental that we protect
workers from the invasion of the rest
time and to ensure
that the right to rest and leisure and
the maximum limit
of the workday are safeguarded we are
calling on the commission
to propose a european directive on the
right to disconnect
the reports provides for the right to
disconnect for all workers in the eu
and it ensures that the digital tools
are used as an
asset benefiting employers and workers
while their adverse
effects are mitigated the report
is also introducing safeguards to
workers from any victimization
or negative repercussions if they use
this right
employer should enforce this right and
not
require workers to be directly or
indirectly
available or reachable outside the
working time and provide them with
sufficient information
and methods to support the right to
disconnect we either
provide workers with the right to
disconnect or turn
our backs at them my choice is clear
i hope you can all support the right to
disconnect
for all european workers thank you